welcome back everybody there is a new
locally owned and operated veterinarian
in town and they are ready to serve and
care for your pets here's dr gill of pet
of canyon pet hospital
this is canyon pet hospital we
are a full-service animal hospital we're
going to be seeing mostly cats and dogs
but we love all animals
so what separates us from other
hospitals is um
it's going to be a very personable
experience we're going to tailor to your
pets needs
it's not assembly line medicine here so
you know
that's something that is like our core
value
second thing is uh transparency so um
you're not gonna be hit with uh you know
some sort of prizes i think surprises
should be left for
like birthdays and anniversaries so um
you'll know what we're doing
uh the procedure we're gonna perform and
uh
you know everything's gonna be explained
to you in detail and uh like i said it's
gonna be very transparent
it's a full-service animal hospital um
you know just general
vaccines which we're to do low-cost
vaccines low-cost dentals
and you know surgeries ranging from like
space and neuters to
like more complicated orthopedic
surgeries so we're going to be here for
the community we do have these extended
hours
we're going to be here 8 a.m to 8 p.m
and i know a lot of times people want to
come in after hours so we're going to be
here when the community needs us and the
techniques there
so on top of that we'll be open for
emergencies and
walk-ins are welcome it's going to be
easy to make an appointment and
we'll you know like i said we'll be here
when we when you guys need us so we're
going to offer uh
wellness plans uh for pets it's going to
have a
it's going to be at a very economical
price of 34.99 a month
it's going to offer prophylactic
treatments
vaccines and testing so we make it
really easy for
you to make an appointment give us a
call head to our website
all right stop by canyon pet hospital on
west sky canyon park drive for a free
first time exam
all you got to do is call 702-922-4444